( intro music )
( applause )
Marc Kaufman:
Well, hello everyone.
I... it's a delight
for me to be here
and to see all of you here.
Ah, and I think this is going
to be a very interesting
and, uh, pleasurable evening.
It certainly will be for us.
So, I want to start
by telling you
a little bit about Mars.
A headshot of Mars,
taken by the Hubble
and showing in, I think
really wonderful detail
what the place kind of
looks like.
In the modern era,
when the Mariner flybys
went past Mars,
they found some things
that were really interesting,
deep canyons and so on.
That increased interest
in sending
a real, sophisticated
mission there and
that resulted
in the Vikings spaceships
and before taking off,
you may recall Carl Sagan
who is a wonderful and
incredibly talented person
nonetheless wanted cameras
on Viking to see the animals.
There was a great expectation
that there was going to be
not only life,
but like weird life,
big life, you know, cool life.
So when they arrived
and they saw
a lot of rocks, uh,
it was kinda disappointing
and there was a big debate about
whether or not there was any
discovery of microbial life,
something that
NASA itself has said
'No', one of the PI's says
'Yes'.
It all ended in both confusion
and disappointment,
for the most part.
As a result Mars funding
and Mars exploration
took a serious dip,
ah, and it wasn't
until 1997 that
the next lander
came on to Mars.
By the way, just an aside,
there have been six successful
landings on Mars
and without being
nationalistic about this,
they are all done by NASA.
It's like what we do really,
really well.
Putting that aside--
( applause )
Putting that aside,
ah... so in '97...
the Sojourner arrives
and then soon after
Spirit and Opportunity,
the two little plucky rovers
that could arrive
and they do
all kinds of things,
however, they did not have
capabilities to do anything
like what Curiosity can do.
But before we get into
Curiosity, I want to tell you
a little bit about what--
what NASA and other
and scientists
were generally looking for,
which was...
Remember the mantra,
'follow the water'?
Well, initially that was like
looking for little gullies
and looking for, you know,
maybe little streams
or spouts that were coming out
in some way or signs
that there had
once been large,
catastrophic floods and so on.
But, when first the Mars
Orbiter camera went up
and then later HiRise
and others
they began seeing
images like these,
which sure looks like
a delta to me, doesn't it?
You know, it's like
that could be the Amazon,
that could be, uh,
the Potomac dried out.
Badly dried out, bad drought.
And the whole notion of
'follow the water'
took on a very
different meaning because
it was clear that there were
signs, many, many signs
that there was
significant water
that had run on the surface.
And all of the climate
modeling said
that wasn't possible
but yet it was the case.
Also, this picture
which is not a Jackson Pollock
but rather
an image of Mawrth Vallis,
which is one of
the oldest sections of Mars
and after it became clear that
there were signs of water,
then they began looking
for minerals.
There are classes of minerals
that are formed only in water,
uh... phyllosilicates
which are clays,
sulfates, some others.
And they began finding those.
Ah, so, they had
this orbital information,
now it was the time
to do something called
'ground-truthing'
which is Curiosity.
Send Curiosity to the ground
and let's see what happens.
This is the heat shield
leaving--
You may recall that Curiosity
in its 'seven minutes
of terror'
where it hit the atmosphere
with 32,000 miles an hour,
it had seven minutes
to stop to zero.
Here is the sequence
going down,
the black is indeed black sand
alongside of Mount Sharp,
which is the big mountain
in the middle of the crater.
Here the thrusters are going,
they are about to land,
at this point,
it's largely the rover itself
and the descent device.
And then, first picture
ever of an actual landing.
Look at it,
that's the tire right there,
that's the tire of Curiosity
about to land.
And it did.
It became clear
quite soon that
this was-- that they landed
in a place
that was very different than
other landing sites
previously.
They found pebbles
that were very interesting
because they seemed to suggest
the presence of water
at some point.
They found other...
conglomerate rocks
that did the same
and also they were
in the proximity to
what appeared to be
a fossil stream.
All of which are beyond cool
from the perspective
of people interested in Mars.
So, and the original plan was
to go directly to Mount Sharp,
which is this huge mountain
in the middle.
A two mile high mountain
in the middle of the crater,
but they decided against that,
and decided instead
to take a detour to
what turned out to be
named Yellowknife Bay.
Now look at this.
What does that look like?
A dried up lake, right?
What do you think it was?
A dried up lake.
You know
that's kind of the conclusion
that they came to probably.
Nothing like this has
ever been seen on Mars before
or any other planet
outside of the Earth.
And it is
an enormous breakthrough.
To your upper-left
is Mount Sharp
and that is
where they didn't go.
But they-- ( laughter )
they will go,
because
that's what the program says
they are supposed to go to.
Alright,
now the red planet, right?
Mars, the red planet.
Every story except for mine
says it's the red planet.
I say, 'No, it's not red.
It has rouge on it'.
( laughter )
This... this shows a rock
that was run over
by the Rover.
And look
what color it is inside.
Bluish gray.
And it turns out that
most of Mars is colors
other than red.
That's just an iron oxide dust
that kinda covers things.
So, the red planet?
I don't think so.
The blue-green planet?
Maybe.
Curiosity has
an array of instruments
that are unlike anything
that has gone before.
This was obviously
taken before they took off.
This is the arm.
Seven feet long with a turret
that has
drilling equipment on it,
that has a camera on it,
that has a number of
other instruments on it.
Again, nothing like this has
ever gone to Mars.
Really, really hard,
you know, to make this work,
it's very heavy.
This is the first drill.
Right in the middle,
you see the thing go down,
it's drilling a hole that's
about half an inch wide,
if I remember correctly,
about two inches deep.
And what they found it was
something that made clear
that the redness just
covered over a level of
potentially interesting,
habitable,
potentially habitable
environments
that we didn't know about
before.
Alright,
how does Curiosity get around?
It's interesting.
This is called
'driving blind',
where what's blind
is not the people
or JPL driving this
but rather the rover,
which has its own autonomous
abilities.
But here it is driving
based on a program
that was sent up to it.
Rover drivers
are well-known to be among
the coolest people on Earth,
but in fact they don't drive.
I mean they make programs,
right?
You know...
they are not at the wheel.
But it is nonetheless
a remarkable and
very, very difficult job.
And with a lot of pressure.
It turns out that after
a year and a half or so,
some serious holes
came up in the wheels,
various punctures and rips.
This came from
going over sharp rocks
that were embedded into
a sandstone as opposed
to being in something
that would be like sand,
where there wouldn't be
as much force.
And this is,
you know, serious problem.
They really did a lot of work
figuring out
how to deal with it
and they determined that
it would not
ultimately affect the mission.
That it would not shorten
the mission in any way
because
they could drive backwards.
( laughter )
And that's what they do now,
they drive backwards.
Unfortunately,
the autonomous part
which is what makes them go
really far cannot go backwards
and so they have to stop,
going backwards.
Then turn around, and then
do the autonomous part
forward,
which is part of the reason
why it's taken a long time
to get to Mount Sharp.
But in any case, there you go.
Very briefly, October 19th
there is a comet
that is going to go past Mars.
Initially they thought
that it was going to hit Mars
or it could hit Mars,
which considering
the billions of dollars
that NASA has on Mars
and around Mars
needless to say,
it was not a happy thought.
But they now believe it will
go to the side enough
that it won't be
a serious danger,
though you can never tell
exactly what happens.
The dust particles themselves,
although they are just
dust particles,
are moving at something like
153,000 miles... an hour?
An hour.
Which makes them
basically bullets,
so they could go through
anything.
In any case, this is going
to be passing by Mars.
And to me it was
really an interesting
reflection on where we--
where we are as people.
There are-- we are now
a space fearing civilization.
We-- something can
come close to Mars
and it matters to us.
And we can learn
an enormous amount from that.
This comet will come
closer to Mars
than any comet has come
to Earth in recorded history.
So, that is what we can
really get a lot out of it
because of having the assets
that we have there now.
And let me just end
with this image
from the camera
that my colleague here,
Ken Edgett, is the PI for it.
You know those are
little grains of sand.
Those are little grains
of dust.
In terms of Mars up-close,
I mean,
they are getting really,
really up-close
and not just
in terms of the images.
In terms of the geo-chemistry,
in terms of the geology,
in terms of understanding
weather
and all kinds of,
and radiation and the like.
And that's what I think is...
is the great message
that comes from
the Curiosity Mission so far,
which is that they are
learning an enormous amount
because they have new tools
and they are right there...
really seeing stuff.
( applause )
( outro music )